all right there we go a bit of a false
start there it is Monday March 30th and
we are standing by for today's White
House coronavirus press briefing we are
about 10 minutes away from the scheduled
time your guess is as good as mine as to
what the actual start time is going to
be we may be 15 days from the peak of
coronavirus now what that means I will
explain momentarily glad everybody's
joining me we are live on YouTube
Twitter twitch as well as Facebook we
will be listening to the comments from
the president today no doubt my
prediction would be that today a lot of
the focus is going to be around the Navy
ship docking in New York City and how
will now it will now be available Trump
will probably wax poetic about how it
was gotten ready quicker than anything
anybody has ever done in history there
is going to be certainly a lot of
bragging about how Trump acted swiftly
and he did everything great and then
maybe we'll hear something that makes
sense from one of the doctors and maybe
we will get some questions that make
sense from some of the reporters that's
basically what we can hope for at this
point in time and these press
conferences have widely turned into
propaganda dissemination centers and so
what I tried to do is to fact-check
in real time when Trump says something
that's not true I tried to tell you that
it's not true so that we all sort of get
on what what could sort of be considered
to be the same page in some way shape or
form I've got a few things that I want
to go over with you of course I want to
thank people who are ascending super
chats already Lee Douglas says whose
baby were you holding in the photo we've
got a meme contest going on it was a
friend's baby and it's big it's being
turned into memes and it's very funny I
also want to say thanks to Alex Ali now
Ska's who has grabbed a youtube
subscription want to say thank you - I
am Compu bear for cheering on twitch as
well as epaulettes
for subscribing on Twitch as well so a
few different things to go over the
official number of coronavirus cases
right now is about seven hundred and
seventy five thousand three quarters of
a
million plus a little bit we are at
37,000 deaths
37,000 deaths the numbers today the US
has added 16,000 new cases and 368
deaths yesterday 363 deaths and 20,000
new cases things in Italy are still very
ugly things in Spain are getting even
worse Germany continuing to have a high
test high case number but still
maintaining a relatively low death rate
although what was before a point 4.5%
death rate is now climbing to about 1
percent based on known cases looking
specifically that's the wrong spot
looking specifically at us numbers we
will pull those up now sorry here we go
officially a hundred and sixty thousand
cases and we will likely eclipse three
thousand deaths today remember Donald
Trump saying that we were unlikely to
have any deaths when we had 15 cases he
said 15 cases will probably go to zero
we now have officially a hundred and
sixty thousand cases and almost 3,000
people have died note that yesterday
Donald Trump shifted his rhetoric from
saying that we may have very few deaths
- saying that if we have no more than
200,000 deaths he would consider that he
did a very good job my how quickly
things change here in Massachusetts we
are now approaching 6000 known cases and
maintaining roughly that 1% death rate
of course the you know I know people
where the whole family clearly had it
one person had a test and tested
positive that's like four cases but it's
officially only counting as one and also
rapidly Florida is becoming a center and
it is gonna be Florida is gonna be a
major major problem I was supposed to be
in Miami today I'm not and I'm glad for
that because Florida is absolutely
exploding let's look at the latest
estimates about what we are expecting in
terms of peak peak days okay this is a
very good website kovat 19 health data
org this is a website and forecast
maintained by dr. Christopher Murray we
are trying to get him on the program
doctor medical doctor and also directs
the depart
of Health metrics Sciences very very
important we are now estimating peak
resource use and peak death day are
going to be April 15 okay now it's
really important to understand every day
we get more data this confidence
interval this range tightens up so the
midpoint of the range is the dotted line
this red area is the point of
uncertainty right so when we get to
today we know how many deaths we had you
don't have this light red cone of
uncertainty sort of like with with a a
weather projection a hurricane for
example this website I see a lot of
people want to look this up and I
encourage you to Cove it 19 dot health
data org okay right now this was updated
from yesterday the peak is expected to
be April 15 with 2271 deaths on that day
now the uncertainty tells us it's gonna
be in the range of eleven eighty to
3,500 right that could be the range
we'll see as we get closer now what's
important to understand is when you peak
that doesn't mean it's directly down
because April 15th is the peak but the
day before the peak April 14th has
almost the exact same number of deaths
April 13 has almost the exact same
number of deaths so we are going to be
above 2,000 deaths per day according to
this model between April 10th all the
way over to April 22nd so the the peak
will likely last close to two weeks and
then we will see a descent this also
estimates the total number of deaths and
this is important during this wave when
we talk about two hundred thousand
deaths
we're talking probably about a three
wave process where we will have this
wave we will have one in the fall and we
will have one in 2021 that's the
expectation this wave now expecting
about 82,000 deaths but again the range
could be anywhere between 39,000 all the
way up to a hundred and forty-two
thousand every day we get a little more
data and that cone of uncertainty can be
tightened up right now it's in the 40
140 there's a hundred thousand variants
each day that variants will get smaller
as the projections can become more
precise very very important stuff and
all of this assumes the same social
distancing methods are continued one
other thing you can also change this
website so for example the national peak
is expected to be April 15 we can take a
state like for example my state of
Massachusetts we started distancing on
you know every state has its own
trajectory the projected peak here is a
day later than national april 16th we
might choose another state like New York
which started earlier and indeed the
expected peak there is 5 days earlier
April 10th
this shifts every single day very
important website I recommend checking
it out according to this again New York
would peak on April 10th with 800 deaths
but April 9th 9th would be almost the
same number April 8th would be close we
would be at these Peaks for a while the
peaks are not one day they are long and
if you look for example if we believe
that Italy has peaked Michael Leavitt
tweeted yesterday that he believes Italy
has peaked you see that the peak lasts a
long time it's not been moving higher
but not drastically lower since March
19th it's now March 30th this has been
roughly 11 days the hope is that soon
these numbers would start coming down so
that's the latest there okay let me get
to some of the messages that folks are
sending and thanks some people and I
have much more to talk about let me say
thank you to al h 9700 with a twitch
subscription from Bordeaux France I
appreciate that thank you very much
super chats are coming in joe kracken
berg says why about Tara Reid how does
this affect Biden I believe it's not
going to affect him greatly
that's my instinct Josh Compton says
love your show man any chance we could
get an elements of Packman or elements
of democracy shirt you know maybe right
now let let me actually address this now
because this is this is kind of a big
so in the first like week of the
shutdown thankfully we were basically
doing fine we weren't seeing a lot of
membership cancellations YouTube revenue
was fine
we were pumping out data mail shirts and
all of that stuff in the last week its
I'm not gonna sugarcoat it it's gotten
pretty bad so YouTube revenue is down
about 40 35 40 percent which is really
really a problem for us our gear
manufacturer has shut down so we're
gonna have to shut down orders because
we're not gonna be able to fulfill them
they're shut down because of kovat 19
advertisers are starting to bail because
they are see like for example we have an
advertiser that said people aren't
buying our product because they don't
have money so we want to shut down
advertising which means we then also
lose out so things are kind of rough
right now so I would not expect any new
shirts anytime soon but maybe on the
other side of this we will start to to
do some of that this is why I really am
being sincere when I say that we really
are mostly funded by people who grab
memberships on our website particularly
now that YouTube's down 35% so if I
don't want your last $2 right I
understand what's going on but if you do
appreciate the work we're doing and can
afford a membership for a couple bucks a
month go to join pakman.com you can use
that coupon code 20/20 now it's very
much appreciated because that I'm not
sugarcoating it it's it's you know
everybody always likes to pretend
everything is exploding audience wise
we're doing great the YouTube channel
all of the twitch Facebook you know
we're now getting three million views a
month on Facebook that's all doing great
the monetization has gone the wrong
direction and I get it if you're you
know if you're on unemployment you're
gonna cancel your david pakman show
membership before you forgo paying your
rent I totally get it so I'm telling you
guys the situation and that's why I've
been so appreciative of people signing
up speaking of which Jakob Johansson is
new member number one today
at join pakman.com boom there it is
starting us off always very very much
appreciated okay let's see here max says
name a US president president that would
handle this worse I can
I mean I I can't think of a president
that would handle this worse than Donald
Trump has and tomorrow on the show I'm
actually going to do it do a story about
is the u.s. actually losing superpower
status because of Donald Trump's bungled
handling of coronavirus I believe the
answer is yes people are looking to
Germany people are looking to South
Korea nobody is looking to the US and
Trump likes to claim that they are but
it's not the case it's simply not the
case that'll be on tomorrow's show
waffles gerald's says anyone noticed
Biden's pisghetti with Kimmel didn't see
it Bryan Holaday says I'm in Brooklyn
had to stop working at my parents
laundromat because I have symptoms of
kovat 19 please everyone stay safe yes
please do what policies of Trump do you
disagree with says Alexander Jones
almost all of them almost all of them I
think Trump is right to extend social
distancing to April 30 otherwise I
disagree with him on almost everything
and I have hundreds of clips on my
youtube channel explaining those in
detail Seamus Doyle grabs a membership
on YouTube Zack Bushman says the deep
literacy article you linked was great
yeah let me pull that up I recently
tweeted extremely important article
highly recommend this is a book title
and the title of this article is the
erosion of deep literacy by Adam
Garfinkel and it explains how we have a
vicious cycle of social media causing
people being out of practice with like
deep reading that means like you know
you sit with theory for an hour maybe
having to reread a lot of the same parts
multiple times to gain a deep
understanding of it that allows you to
then when you're presented with problems
in your everyday life think them through
and when you look at someone like Trump
who hasn't read a book I mean certainly
in 30 years I don't want to say ever he
probably read a book sometime but Trump
hasn't read a book in 30 years and then
someone has to sit down and say listen
we have this coronavirus thing but to
even understand coronavirus you've got
to understand infectious disease you've
got to understand
viral math you have to understand all of
these different things to even get at
the problem Trump can't do it and this
is not about the article is not about
Trump and so you know one of the things
I'm focusing on during this
self-isolation period is I'm trying to
get I do a lot of reading anyway but not
as much as I would like to I probably
read 30 to 50 pages a day of nonfiction
stuff I'm trying to get up - can I get
it - up to a hundred pages you know
people like Bill Gates and Warren
Buffett say they read 500 pages a day
this is how the article describes
something called social autism and it's
not a pejorative term but it points out
that you have so many high school
students who lack the social skills from
being able to sit down for forty five
intense minutes with like a college
counselor to talk about what are your
interests how do different colleges
differ wearing it's a real problem and
again that term social autism not being
used not being used even remotely
pejoratively I want to be really clear
about that okay
other sorry for the tangent other super
chats parrot Aaron says if you compare
Cuomo's press conference with Trump it's
like a balm for the Soul - an acid bath
take care I would love to be doing more
streaming of cuomo and gavin newsom and
others
we're just usually filming the Reg at
the broadcast show at that time which is
why I've not been doing it but you are
absolutely right absolutely right Cuomo
has been very good and you know that now
there's a it's like the woke left is
starting to tweet about oh we have live
video let me actually get to that
because I don't want to miss what's
going on it looks like this will be
another outdoor press conference they
said you know the woke left loves to
just be contrarian no matter what and so
now that a lot of us are saying hate
Cuomo is handling this like an adult
they say whoa but he he also wanted this
and that thing some other does anybody
doubt that Cuomo should be handling this
nationally rather than Donald Trump
that's the point that we're making
imagine what it would be like to have a
president who understands stuff that's
the point you don't have to agree with
everything that Andrew Cuomo has ever
said Daniel Krieger says lucky to still
have my job will
keep supporting you Thank You Daniel
thank you so much I appreciate that
Miz Smith says thank you for keeping it
sane
Clayton Sackett says trying to support
you the best I can my man I joined
yesterday but I'm curious what perks do
I have now how do I utilize them
oh sorry hold on a second we do have to
let me see here we've got to just ban
some people we have said that the amount
of toxic trolling on the on the YouTube
channel is crazy hey can a moderator ban
the user Alexander Jones who's just
putting the same message over and over
and over again and then we also have to
Sharm Mohammed we've got to get out of
he can't come on guys we're dealing with
serious stuff here
cut cut the trolling for once it seems
like things are actually more
respectable over on on Twitch usually it
gets out of control on Twitch but today
it's completely out of control on
YouTube Clayton says what perks do I get
how do I utilize them so I if you mean
that you joined on my website join
pakman.com you get all of the member
content by logging in and then just
click on member content if you mean a
different platform let me know and then
we can like we can help you now they're
bringing a table up and usually when
Trump is around a table like that it's
for propaganda purposes so I I don't
know what sort of propaganda is going to
be facilitated by this table they're
also figuring out putting a presidential
seal on the table so that's interesting
I don't know what to expect but I would
expect a significant amount of
propaganda this is an element of
propaganda that table we know under
Trump is an element of propaganda it may
be set up for him to go over and sign
something that's a possibility what are
they putting on there what is that is it
is that a picture of the corona virus
what does that say does that say Kovan
oh you know what this might be this
might be like a box of the very popular
and exciting coronavirus product the
15-minute Abbot test that would be my
guess as to what that is but we'll see
see it's certainly a prop okay let me
say thank you to sweet tooth for
subscribing with twitch prime also to
rzl Oh for cheering a hundred bits let's
do some new member thank-yous okay I
have some really really great people
that I want to thank here let me see
here we're about to blow this thing out
of the water okay I think Jacob already
Roland Webster Rowland is new member
number two at join pakman.com will
Robinson is new member number 3 at join
pakman.com Mary Allen is new member
number 4 at join pakman.com Ellen
classica SP ow has upgraded her
membership we're going to count it as
member number 5 today also want to say
thanks to Michael lapacho who is member
number 6 today Paul day is new member
number 7 marine Noel brass it is new
member number 8 Thank You Marie very
much appreciate that Ricardo Diaz is new
member number 9 today at join pakman.com
Alexander Hofstra I think of a professor
when someone says Alexander Hofstra new
member number 10 also want to say thanks
to Fabian slap fer who is new member
number 11 today at joined pakman.com
really appreciate it yeah as I mentioned
earlier we're doing what we can here at
the show we've not you know done any
layoffs or our reductions but YouTube
revenue is down about 35% because
advertisers are pulling out of YouTube
we have we lost one sort of
one-and-a-half important advertisers
that are saying nobody's buying our
stuff right now so we we need to
postpone more ads so we are really
increasingly dependent on on the
memberships on the website which is the
way that's the way the systems design
the the way we designed everything is we
have all these revenue sources that go
up and down they're unpredictable but
the idea is we control the process on
our website that's where people can
always sign up and it's not subject to
an algorithm or advertisers or whatever
the case may be and yes the coupon code
2029
is not means-tested you don't have to
there's no you don't have to provide any
documentation if you want the 66%
discount you can take it with the coupon
code 20/20 now available at any time
literally at any time of day okay
other super chats coming in Fredro says
thanks for all the great coverage glad
to help out you out moderating keep up
the great work
Thank You Frasier I appreciate that
Charlie says David are you Bitcoin only
or do you hold any other kryptos at this
point I basically only hold I have the
big three Bitcoin aetherium and litecoin
and then merely because we we post on
steam it and hive I've got a bunch of
steam and and hive dollars but I don't
really do anything with them I did one
of the moves I made when the crash
happened was to get a little more
Bitcoin as a possible hedge it may or
may not work as a hedge
you know kim.com was tweeting it's gonna
be it's gonna be a hedge it crashed then
it recovered you know I don't know but I
am mostly Bitcoin when it comes to
crypto but it's like a tiny amount of of
what I've got Walker Anderson says
doesn't the Democratic Party's treatment
of Tara Reid show clear hypocrisy as the
Trump is who doesn't fit into your three
categories I'd love some balance check
out tomorrow's show Zachary Monroe hey
Zach Zach says I was aware of the virus
in December my family thought I was
crazy when I told them that this was
going to spread outside of China it took
them until a week ago to take this virus
seriously
hashtag support independent media yeah
on that note I'll turn the volume up
here so that will will hear when things
get going but I had a couple clips to
play for you this is from Donald Trump
yesterday without evidence accusing
hospitals of hoarding or stealing
ventilators take a look at this via the
states are stocked up some of them don't
admit it but they have we have sent just
so much so many things to them and
including ventilators you know there's a
question as to hoarding of ventilators
some hospitals and independent hospitals
and some hospital chains as we call them
they are holding ventilators they don't
want to let them up we need that okay
actually that's not the right clip the
one about stealing the stuff was where
was that where was the Trump stealing
the stuff one you know what I I think I
have the wrong so anyway yeah I don't I
I don't have it I'm unable to pull it up
right now actually let's see if I just
search for Trump masks 200k maybe I can
find it under videos from masks stealing
and I should spell stealing correctly
otherwise we're not gonna find it here
it is going are they going out the back
door but where the mask going are they
going out the back door how do you go
from ten thousand to three hundred
thousand yeah so anyway Trump
yesterday's suggesting that they were
going out the back door falling off a
truck of course when you do the math
when you understand you need a new mask
for every patient you test you're
supposed to change masks between
patients in general you very quickly see
when you've got you know fifty thousand
people or however many in New York three
hundred thousand masks is very very
reasonable one other thing I wanted to
go over with you guys there is now more
and more gentleman the President of the
United States oh and the Vice President
of the United States it looks like
things are starting sorry we'll get to
that later so this time is no big
contingent it looks like it's just the
two of them different situation we have
a propaganda table there so we'll see
where this goes it feels like a
different thing thank you
it's very comfortable here a lot of room
and we appreciate you being here
yesterday I announced that we would be
extending our social distance guidelines
through the end of April this is based
on modeling that shows the peak in
fatalities will not arrive for another
two weeks the same modeling also shows
that by very vigorously following these
guidelines we could save more than 1
million American lives down there on
million American lives our future is in
our own hands and the choices and
sacrifices we make will determine the
fate of this virus and really the fate
of our victory we will have a great
victory we have no other choice every
one of us has a role to play in winning
this war
every citizen family and business can
make a difference in stopping the virus
this is our shared patriotic duty
challenging times are ahead for the next
30 days and this is a very vital 30 days
we're sort of putting it all on the line
this 30 day is so important because we
have to get back yes but the more we
dedicate ourselves today the more
quickly we will emerge on the other side
of the crisis yes it's not a hug that's
the time we're waiting for the more we
commit ourselves now the sooner we can
win the fight and return to our lives
and there will be great lives may be
better than ever today we reached a
historic milestone in our war against
the corona virus over 1 million
Americans have now been tested more than
any other country by far not even close
and tested accurately and I think what
I'd like to do is ask not per capita a
czar who's done a fantastic job to come
up and just say a few words about the
fact that we reached substantially now
more than 1 million
tests please thank you Alex low per
capita of course well thank you mr.
president for your leadership in
marshaling all the resources that we
have for this unprecedented testing
effort that's all thank you mr. vice
president for leading a whole of economy
approach to testing as the president
mentioned today the United States hit
more than 1 million samples tested a
number that no other country has reached
we're now testing nearly 100,000 samples
a day also a level that no other country
has reached I want to thank every
partner that has been involved in this
effort that includes all of the men and
women of the FDA and the CDC including
director Redfield and commissioner Han
together the FDA and CDC of work to
balance the need for testing on an
aggressive scale with the scientific
rigor that Americans expect working with
our testing coordinator Admiral Scheer
WA they have now truly unleashed the
ingenuity of the private sector and our
state and local leaders the centerpieces
of America's historic approach to
testing I want to thank those state and
local leaders who have used their
on-the-ground resources and knowledge to
lead testing and make it much more
easily accessible to the Americans who
need it I'm also grateful to FEMA with
whom we are now working closely to get
state and local partners what they need
I also want to thank CMS where
administrator Verma has given health
care providers unprecedented flexibility
to scale up capacity for testing and
treatment and has ensured that tests
will be paid for finally we would not be
where we are today without the many
American companies entrepreneurs and
scientists who have worked day and night
to develop as of today 20 different
emergency testing options with the FDA
responding to requests for authorization
tip typically within 24 hours the number
of options is growing nearly every day
FDA has also opened up new options for
using the available tests like self
swabbing and new options for swab I also
want to thank FDA and other components
of HHS for incredibly
rapid action on other tools that we need
this weekend we actually work to secure
30 million tablets from Sandoz and 1
million tablets from Bayer of
hydroxychloroquine and chloroquine which
are potential kovat 19 treatments would
be good to know more about authorized
Patel's new decamp decontamination
machines which can each sterilize
thousands of essential and 95 maps for
reuse every day so thank you mr.
president for your leadership and thank
you to everybody who's played a part in
getting us where we are today by the way
Tom tons of talk about shipping things
to places and also about securing things
I want to actually see things delivered
I want someone to say we received
minitest
highly accurate and I maybe can show
that as we listen to our FDA
Commissioner the job he's done and the
approval process we talked about the
cleric win and the hydroxychloroquine
just now I thought that I'd mentioned it
but alex has already done that but we
have that now under tests with 1,100
people in New York and it was only the
fast approval by FDA that allowed us to
do that it was a really rapid approval
and dr. police say a few words and this
is the first one on the line of the five
minute test so my as I pointed out that
was likely that quick test mr. president
for your leadership Thank You mr. vice
president for your leadership of the
task force I'm very proud of FDA staffs
work in the last few months to expedite
the availability of testing in this
country I'm also incredibly appreciative
of private industries ingenuity and
willingness to work with us quickly to
develop and distribute those tests we've
had a substantial addition to testing
with the authorization of point-of-care
tests unboxing the Abbott point of care
test which the president has pulled out
of the box a point-of-care test is a
test that gives you a result where
you're getting care this is truly a
patient-centered approach whether it's
the doctor's office a hospital and
emergency room at urgent care center or
a drive-by testing site this is a big
deal just like tests for flu
or strep we go to the doctor's you get
the test done you can get an answer
within minutes of having this test done
now with those tests being approved for
abbott and for others these are
available around the country they're
planning to scale up the number of tests
that can be put out throughout the
country over the next month and patients
can get the answer within as little as
15 to 5 minutes and then of course an
appropriate plan of treatment can be
given
we at FDA are working quickly with
Abbott as well and other testing
approaches and normally these tests take
months to develop I was on the phone
today with the Abbott CEO he told me
that normally this is a 9 to 12 month
approach to developing a point-of-care
test they did this in collaboration with
FDA and US government within weeks
albert has shared that they will be
delivering these tests tomorrow and then
will be ramping up just to emphasize one
thing the most innovative and safe
products come from the private sector in
partnership with government always have
to mention the private sector approach
just like in this case and the other
point here is that advant and FDA work
together to make sure that we had a fast
reliable and accurate test to market
thank you exciting new product for
coronavirus job thank you Steve
so the pharmaceutical company Sandoz has
been working with us very closely and as
Alex mentioned a little bit 30 million
doses of the hydroxychloroquine to the
United States government it's been given
and bear has donated 1 million doses of
the chloroquine which will soon be
distributed to States and state health
officials around the country Teva
Pharmaceuticals tefa is also donating 6
million doses of hydroxychloroquine to
US hospitals 6 million doses so the
private sector as you'd say Steve it's
been amazing what's happened really
amazing
and we're going to introduce you to some
of the greatest business executives in
the world today no matter where you go
and they're gonna say a little bit about
what they're doing great commercial we
have so many more the FDA is also
authorized the Patels n95 respirator
mask sterilization kits it's an
incredible thing I've been asking why
are we throwing these masks away you
look at some of these masks and they're
significant pieces of equipment and I
say how come you throw them away why
aren't they using sterilization
techniques genius I got a call from Mike
DeWine the governor of Ohio and he's a
tremendous guy tremendous governor and
he said we have a company named batil
and they're having a hard time getting
approval from the FDA and I called up
dr. Hahn and within a very short period
of time they got the approval Steve we
really appreciate it I want to thank
Mike and I want to thank Steve and
they're gonna be able each machine now
can disinfect 120,000 masks per day now
think of that each machine can disinfect
120,000 masks per day it'll be just like
a new one it could go up to about 20
times for each mask
so each mask can go through this process
20 times and they have to in Ohio one in
New York and one will soon be shipped to
Seattle Washington and also to
Washington DC so that's going to make a
tremendous difference on the masks this
morning I spoke to our nation's
governor's to help each state get the
medical supplies they need and yesterday
Vice President Mike Pence asked our
nation's hospitals to begin reporting
total bed capacity ICU bed capacity
ventilator capacity and vital medical
supply levels on a daily basis yes and
Mike thank you for the great job thank
you very much
in New York the 2900 bed hospital under
construction which is now completed they
completed it in three days you might say
three and a half days at the Javits
Center will be completed today will be
and when you look so they're going up I
think we're going to be adding some more
beds which will be completed today and
we've opened up whoops there goes our
box the hair is getting a little crazy
and it's mine the one thing you can't
get away with it is that usually got a
problem if you're president and nearly
3,000 medical beds will become
operational the US Navy ship comfort
also arrived today equipped with 12
operating rooms and 1,000 hospital beds
work has begun on an additional
temporary hospital sites including a 600
bed capacity nursing home facility in
Brooklyn and numerous floors of a
high-rise building on Wall Street so
it's been really pretty amazing what
they've done the Army Corps of Engineers
what they've done they've done they they
just completed think of it a 2,900 bed
hospital in New York in just about three
days maybe four days and the whole city
is talking about it on top of that we
floated in a great ship which is going
to be a thousand rooms which is being
used for patients outside of what we're
focused on and that will free up a lot
of rooms for what we're focused on so
it's been great the Army Corps of
Engineers is awarded contracts for the
construction of alternate care
facilities also at the State University
at Stony Brook State University Old
Westbury and the Westchester Community
Center were sending 60 ambulances to New
York City today we have a total of 60
were getting some additional ones with
up to 190 more to follow at different
locations to date
FEMA has obligated more than
1.3 million dollars billion dollars in
federal support to the state of New York
so we're spending a lot of money in New
York it's a hot it's a hot bed there's
no question about it
and we're spending a lot of time effort
on New York New Jersey spoke with
Governor Cuomo a lot spoke with governor
Murphy a lot in New Jersey and we're
we're really getting the job done people
are very impressed and I'm very
impressed by the people in FEMA the
people in the Army Corps of Engineers
because what they've done I've never
seen anybody do anything like it
in addition to the 8,100 ventilators
that we've already delivered over the
next 48 hours we're delivering more than
1,000 we're going 400 ventilators are
going to Michigan very shortly 300 going
to New Jersey 150 ventilators to
Illinois 150 to Louisiana and 50 to
Connecticut FEMA and HHS already
delivered 11.6 million n95 respirators
26 million surgical masks 5.3 million
face shields 4.4 million surgical gowns
and 22 million gloves and I don't know
if you just saw it just came over the
wires that Ford just announced just a
little while ago that they will produce
along with General Electric healthcare
50,000 ventilators and they're going to
be doing it in less than 100 days and
top of that we have other companies that
are doing ventilators including General
Motors but we have nine other companies
doing ventilators as we outpace what we
need we're going to be sending up to
Italy we're going to be sending them to
France we're going to be sending them to
Spain where they have tremendous
problems and other countries as we as we
can now things are starting that the
fact that we're doing so many so quickly
is a tribute to our great companies more
than 14,000 National Guard members and
now that there's money to be made things
are rolling guys help supplement state
and
local efforts to distribute personal
protective equipment where we're sending
a lot we have plane loads coming in we
have 51 loads from various locations all
around the world and they're landing we
had our first big cargo plane land this
morning and we're getting it from all
over the world and we're also sending
things that we don't need to other parts
I just spoke to the Prime Minister of
Italy and we have additional capacity we
have additional product that we don't
need we're going to be sending
approximately a hundred million dollars
worth of things of surgical and medical
elements medical things to Italy medical
things and huge so it was very very
happy I will tell you that they're
having a very hard time joining us this
afternoon our CEOs of the great American
companies that are fulfilling their
patriotic duty by producing or donating
medical equipment to help meet our most
urgent needs what they're doing is
incredible and these are great companies
Darius
Dom Scheck of Honeywell you know that
and Darius has been somebody that I've
dealt with in the past dealt with and
he's a great leader of a great company
Deborah Waller of jockey international a
friend of mine Mike Linda Allen my
pillow boy do you sell those pillows not
the Mike Lee local what you do David
Taylor Procter and Gamble and Greg Hayes
of United Technologies Corporation and I
just want to tell all of you that
America is very grateful to you and what
you've done an amazing job you've done
and we thank you very much I'd like you
to come up and say a couple of words if
you might about your companies Mike come
on Trump already handing out coronavirus
Awards apparently you have to say what
you're doing because it's been really
incredible
go ahead Mike is this the my pillow guy
okay well my pillow is a u.s. vertically
integrated company which has been forced
to adjust to the changing business
environment as a result of the pandemic
my pillows uniquely position is a US
company that functions as a manufacturer
logistics management distribute and
direct to consumer given our current
business lines we are experience the
effects of this pandemic firsthand but
my pill is done with the established and
internal Task Force which is monitoring
future needs of companies across the
country as a result of this pandemic and
given our position we've begun to
research and develop new protocols to
address the current and future needs of
US businesses across multiple sectors
how companies are going to prepare
themselves when they once again open up
in and changes to their current
operations in order to adjust to future
threats and pandemics my pill has
designated some of its call center to
help us companies navigate the many
issues that resulted from this pandemic
we've debt we've dedicated 75% of my
manufacturing to produce cotton face
masks I'm up to ten in three days I was
up to 10,000 a day by Friday I want to
be up to 50,000 a day I'm proud to
manufacture our products in the United
States and I'm even more proud to be
able to serve our nation in this great
time of need Thank You mr. president for
your call to action when which has
empowered companies like my pillow to
help our nation win this invisible war
now I wrote something off the cuff to
fight the wars not God gave us grace on
November 8 2016 to change the course we
were on God had been taken out of our
schools and lives a nation had turned
his back on God and I encourage you use
this time at home to get to home to get
back in the word read our Bibles and
spend time with our families our
president gave us so much hope we're
just a few short months ago we had the
best economy the lowest unemployment and
wages going up it was amazing with our
great president vice president and this
administration and all the great
people in this country praying daily we
will get through this and get back to a
place that's stronger and safer than
ever
someone reset the simulation oh he was
gonna do that but he's a friend of mine
and I do appreciate it thank you bye
please first of all mr. president mr.
vice president the entire administration
and all the agencies thank you for your
strong leadership during this time of
crisis it is noticed and it's making a
difference Wow second of all I'd like to
say a big thank you to all the health
care workers out there you're putting
yourself in arms away every day and you
really respect what you're doing and we
couldn't be thankful enough for it and I
can tell you that more helps under way
how is that yes honey well we're an
industrial technology company and one of
the businesses that were in and protect
the industrial worker but what we're
doing today is were repurposing a lot of
that equipment to serve the healthcare
worker a few days ago we announced the
startup of a new manufacturing facility
in Rhode Island we're going to be hiring
500 employees we have already 200 on
board and we're going to be starting the
production of n95 masks within the next
two weeks furthermore today we're
announcing the start up of another
manufacturing facility in Arizona we're
gonna be hiring another 500 people and
we're going to be starting up production
in that facility by the middle of May so
in total we've doubled our production of
n95 masks already it's going to double
again within the next 60 days and then
within the next 90 days one of the 5x2
capacity we do today furthermore we're
going to be providing other safety
equipment to support all the efforts
going on lastly and say a big thank you
to all the Honeywell employees and also
announce a 10 million dollar fund for
them for all the hourly and
administrative employees are having a
hard time during this time of crisis
Thank You mr. president
oh boy thank you
Thank You mr. president and mr. vice
president on your guidance during this
unprecedented time and I'm very honored
to be here today
founded by a minister 144 years ago
Jokke International is a family-owned
company headquartered in Kenosha
Wisconsin since 1876 often providing
socks and underwear for generations of
families it is part of our DNA to roll
up our sleeves and help our country in
her time of need during World War two
we made parachutes for the military and
today we are eager to serve this great
country by providing support for the
health care workers on the frontlines of
this fight as the president and vice
president have said it's a whole of
America approach and we are committed
Jackie has had a long-standing
partnership with encompass Group
headquartered in Georgia serving the
health care community when we learned of
the critical need for PPE we knew we had
to help that meant restarting production
on Tier three isolation gowns monumental
lifting by Jackie encompass are the
commercials almost over DEA was done in
just a few days to be production ready
as a result we expect to begin
delivering 30 to 50,000 gowns per week
helping those that need it the most
right now in addition this week we are
also donating ten thousand units of
scrubs to the frontline doctors and
nurses at the Javits Convention Center
in New York City we would not have been
able to do this without the
collaboration of the administration
representatives from the federal
agencies and congressman Brian Stiles
thank you very much mr. president and
mr. Vyse mr. vice president
adblocks not stopping this
Thank You mr. president mr. vice
president for bringing us together today
I'm proud to be able to represent the
men and women of Procter & Gamble who
every day 24 hours a day are working to
build and make essential cleaning
products hygiene products and health
care products for families everywhere
these include health care workers and
for institutions that are serving those
in the frontline guys got a weird look
P&G people are the faces that brands you
know and trust
brands like Tide pampers ballet Charmin
mr. clean and Vicks in addition to
making packing and shipping these
essential items they've worked together
to transform our plants to make things
we've never made before like hand
sanitizers and facial masks some of
these are already getting to national
state and local agencies some of them
are in the hospitals already everywhere
around the world PNG people working
everyday to serve everybody consumers
and they're working together to bring
together the full capability of our
research and development and our
engineering or manufacturing you know
communications capability to make sure
we make a difference to the consumers we
serve and to all the audience that we
can make a difference to right I want to
thank them and I'm very grateful for
what they do every day in service to
others Thank You mr. president mr. vice
president for brings together today hmm
he didn't mention God like everybody
else or have a big cross hanging from
his neck good afternoon I'm Greg Hayes
from United Technologies and on behalf
of the 240,000 employees of United
Technologies and the 70,000 employees at
Raytheon which will join together with
UTC this is a right can you amount of
all say thank you to the president and
the vice president for your leadership
during what is really a war there's a
different war than anybody has ever
fought before but it's a war that were
uniquely qualified to help imagine
having the world's largest defense
contractors and some of the best
technology we're using that technology
to try and solve some real world
problems today we're working with the
Air Force to try and help pilots as
they're moving medical evacuated the
cove in nineteen various such that they
can be protected and that the patients
can be protected again we're working
also with logistics and if you think
about a war strategy is important but
logistics wins war and some it's
imperative I think with FEMA along with
the mister of Navarro's office that we
coordinate all of these activities last
week we donated about ninety thousand
pieces of personal protective equipment
to FEMA next week we'll have another
almost million again working through our
supply chain partners around the world
we're also today this week beginning the
manufacture of face shields using
additive technologies that we have and
the machines that we have available
within UTC will be able to produce
approximately ten thousand shields in
the next four weeks again all needed
equipment we stand ready to help in any
way we can we don't need the defense
production act to ask us to act all of
the people are UTC and Raytheon are
focused on this war and yeah don't
invoke that thing on us please thank you
too of all of our employees for their
work during this crisis as well as to
the frontline medical and other first
responders thank you very much how can
nobody around these rich CEOs get them
like a properly tailored suit it's very
weird how much I'd like to ask Seema to
come up and say a few words oh god what
you're doing and not cease happening and
how positive it's been I really
appreciate I hope steam is doing as
little as possible Thank You mr.
president
and let me start by saying I want to
convey my deepest sympathies to those
that have lost loved ones to the
coronavirus we're all thinking okay you
know what finally someone mentions the
people dying right and without and I
want to send a message of gratitude to
the foot soldiers in this war men and
women that are providing care and
comfort uh-oh oh boy what just happened
did we lose that stream let's go to this
one to the foot soldiers in this war men
and women that are providing care and
comfort
to America oh they're all cutting at the
exact same spot and affected by the
virus weird your country is grateful and
in short as the president has said we
are engaged in a war against an
invisible enemy in wartime the
assumptions of peacetime must be
revisited and adjusted to meet the
demands of the moment and so under the
president's leadership CMS is waiving a
wide an unprecedented range of
regulatory requirements now many
healthcare systems won't need these
waivers and they shouldn't use them if
they don't need them but the
flexibilities are there in a time of
crisis regulations shouldn't stand in
the way of patient care and there are
several components to our announcement
today but the first one is CMS's
hospitals without walls and this is
going to allow hospital systems to
create new treatment sites outside of
their facility to expand capacity and be
able to safely separate patients that
are infected with the corona virus and
those that are not
now FEMA is doing incredible work
setting up temporary hospitals in New
York and other areas but under these
waivers we are empowering local
communities to complement and augment
the work of FEMA and allowing hospital
systems to tap into the capacity that
already exists in their communities
making use of dorms and hotels or
gymnasiums and allowing the main
hospital to focus on those that need the
most intensive care
there are surgery centers out there
today that are delaying elective
surgeries and they may have excess
capacity that can be devoted to hospital
like care we are also making changes to
the Medicare program to facilitate
testing so some people that need a
coronavirus test can't leave their home
or patients that are in a nursing home
and now we will pay for labs to go out
to these locations and perform testing
and we're also expanding the workforce
we are taking action today to relax some
of our regulations to allow hospitals to
increase their workforce and we're
allowing a broad range of flexibilities
so that we can let health care workers
operate at the
top of their license and we are also
allowing our hospitals to give to
provide more support for our healthcare
workers under today's regulations they
can only provide minimal support to
healthcare workers but now we're going
to allow them to provide childcare meals
laundry services and then there's also
telehealth the president already
directed a dramatic expansion of
telehealth to our nation's 62 million
seniors with Medicare and we're so proud
of all the health care health care
providers and patients that have rapidly
implemented telehealth right but today
we're announcing that we're gonna go
even further and we're gonna be paying
for doctors to make phone calls with
their patients and provide care over the
phone and we're getting rid of
long-standing barriers to telehealth in
the Medicare program allowing emergency
rooms to use telehealth and eliminating
requirements that some does it's be
provided face-to-face and I also want to
mention that on Saturday the president
directed CMS to offer advance payments
for health care providers that are
experiencing cash flow problems we know
that many providers are complying with
our recommendations to delay
non-essential elective surgeries and
they shouldn't be penalized for doing
the right thing now I've barely
scratched the surface of all the
flexibilities that we are offering
health care workers and health care
systems these flexibilities will provide
a lot of flexibility from regulations
that are ill-suited to the unprecedented
needs of this emergency and doctors and
nurses and other health care
professionals that are working long
hours and sacrificing times with their
families and risking their lives we'll
have the flexibility that they need to
confront the needs of the corona virus
pandemic and there are many heroes in
this war but I want to take an
opportunity to thank the team at CMS
these folks have worked day and
night the flexibilities that are in this
regulation and any regulation usually
takes EMS a year but we did this in two
weeks and I couldn't be more honored and
privileged to serve alongside these
dedicated public servants thank you
thank you very much fantastic yeah and
you're doing a great job so we are in
the midst of something that is very
difficult but we are going to win it's
just a question of when we want to do it
as quickly as possible we want to have
as few deaths as possible and we will
meet again tomorrow for some statistics
and some statistics updates as to where
we are where we think we're going and
timing I think timing is going to be
very important because we have to get
our country back we have to get our
country back to where it was it may be
beyond where it was because we've
learned so much but we will have lost a
lot of people and in many ways they're
heroes and if you look at what's
happening with our medical professionals
it's a danger there they're warriors men
and women are doing a job that the likes
of which I don't think anyone has ever
seen I see them coming out of planes
today going into New York going into the
most dangerous locations dangerous areas
and they go in there and they just want
to do the job and you see the numbers
you see the numbers like I see the
numbers I have some friends that are
unbelievably sick we thought they were
going in for a mild stay and in one case
from conscious in a coma
and you say how did that happen so I
just want to thank all of the great
professionals men and women doctors and
nurses and paramedics and first
responders and law enforcement by the
way if you look at New York and you see
how the effect that that's had in law
enforcement it's been incredible these
are great people
firefighters great people they're
helping in so many different ways so
thank you very much and if you'd like
we'll take a few questions John
here we go
nasty questions mr. president
yesterday you said that you would be
extending the guidelines through the end
of April and that you'd be giving us
specifics tomorrow do you expect it the
guidelines will just carry on the
guidelines that have been in place now
for 15 days could there potentially be
some modification also you have some
travel restrictions that come up for
reconsideration the one from the EU on
April 13th right candidate us-mexico
border
on April the 21st look what will happen
with all the staying and we may add a
few more but the guidelines would be
very much as they are maybe even
toughened up a little bit but they're
having a big impact the right thing
mentis impact it was I think I see it
and that's the key we're starting to see
the in skies the Klan but that's the
right thing and if I could ask you to
you talked about Ford now ramping up
production of ventilators the government
is sending thousands of ventilators
across the country clearly the supply is
increasing but when you look at the
production curve against the
hospitalization curve can you guarantee
that everyone who needs a ventilator in
the next few weeks will be able to get
one well I think that some are ramping
up to a level that they're not going to
have - John and I think that we also
have kept in reserve we have almost
10,000 ventilators in our line we have
them we've held back just because we did
the stockpile we didn't want to give
them because we don't know where the
emergency this hits it's like so fast it
comes so quickly and we have 10,000
we're probably going to send some of
them now we've been sending a lot to
Michigan and various other states will
probably send some additional ones to
Michigan New York's been doing very well
but we can add some more to New York
we're adding them to the areas that are
having a problem even Alabama all of a
sudden flared up a little bit as you saw
over the last couple of days and flare
will send them down to Alabama so we
have 10,000 we kept them for this very
specific purpose it sounds like a lot
but it's not when you
about it but we're making a lot and when
you see they're talking about hundreds
of thousands being made in a very short
period of time because if you look at
what just so we have now ten companies
at least making the ventilators and we
say go ahead because honestly other
countries really they'll never be able
to do it it's a very complex piece of
equipment and it's it's big and
expensive do you believe as we approach
this peak in a couple of weeks that
there will be enough for the American
Pie do so yes I do think so I think
we're gonna be in very good shape and we
had a great call today with the
governors and they were I actually said
I hope that the media is listening to
this call because it was a really good
call and that was randomly government
needs tough and Trump is saying I hope
the media is listening Kratz and
Republicans in there I think for the
most part they were saying thank you for
doing a great job and we discussed that
at the end of the call so it really
people are very happy with what we're
doing now the circumstances are so
terrible because of what's going on but
I think they're very impressed by the
federal government i watch that
beautiful ship floating in today into
you know weeks ahead of schedule almost
four weeks ahead of schedule into New
York Harbor comfort and I watched the
Mersey floating in to Los Angeles a week
ago almost a week ago and they are
stocked they are really ready to go
they're stocked with both talent and
tremendous amounts of equipment and the
Navy and everybody else involved they
got it ready so fast it's just
incredible what they can do they've
geared up that's why I mean I am so
impressed by the people involved Mike
and I were talking about it before the
level of genius to put it all together
so quickly this wasn't a month ago
nobody ever heard of this nobody can I
idea the Mersey worst case was January
20 paned it was in maintenance for a
month
and when they heard we needed it and I
was surprised they said sir we're ready
to go I said what do you mean you're not
going to
ready for three weeks no sir we're all
ready to go it was incredible
so and we've had many instances like
this I think the building of the
hospital two thousand nine hundred beds
in a matter of days a few days is just
incredible Governor Cuomo was impressed
and gavin newsom was impressed by what
we've been doing with gavin and
California and Los Angeles area in
particular but really San Francisco all
over all over California when you look
at what we're doing with Michigan we're
getting along very well with Michigan's
great great place we're sending a lot of
things to Michigan because that's
becoming a hotbed especially a specific
area as you know it's become very hot
it's become I don't know could even at
some point supersede but it's it's got
to be taken care of so we're the
relationship we have with the governor's
I just wish you could because we took a
lot of calls from a lot of different
states and I wish you could have heard
yeah even a thing where like the
Governor of Ohio calls just a reminder
because it's been seven minutes the
question was will anyone who needs a
ventilator in the next two weeks be able
to get one just so you guys know how far
off course we are here he said we'll get
it done and blown out and they got it
done almost immediately and originally
they were approving it for 10,000 masks
and then it was supposed to be 480 and
they ultimately approved it for 120,000
it's a tremendous number and I kept
wondering why aren't they sterilizing
these minutes if I assume maybe you
couldn't do it but then I'd look at them
and they'd let us mentally not cloth
it's something that looks like it could
be sterilized and that's what they've
done and yeah I was trying the machine
that is over there actually they have a
piece of the machine over there and
won't bother showing it to you and this
is incredible when you talk about five
minutes 15 minutes and highly accurate
yeah remember the question was
ventilators being to do as the other
test so we've just gotten better we're
doing things that nobody else ever
thought of please
he has issued staff quarters that
governor wrapped Northern Virginia took
it pretty far he issued a 70 days
stay-at-home order
it's that constitutional first off and
secondly do you think it's warranted to
go ahead and issue 275 there's no law
scholar letting the governors do in
their states pretty much what they want
with our supervision and they consult
with us in all cases some go further
than others as you know I mean I could
give you plenty of examples but I'm not
going to do that because we never want
to be controversial imagine asking Trump
about the Constitution further and
people are questioning people are
questioning that but look staying at
home with respect to what we're talking
about doesn't bother me and all people
should be staying at home that's what we
want
Americans have died from coronavirus in
the last 60 days yeah meanwhile you have
2369 children who are killed by their
mothers through elective abortions each
day tossed around and a half thousand
children killed toss her out two states
have suspended elective abortion to make
more resources to grow for coronavirus
cases that's Texas in Ohio do you agree
with States who are placing coronavirus
victims
above elective abortions and should more
states be doing the same lunatic well I
think what we're doing is we're trying
to as a group governor's and that's
Republicans and Democrats yet we're just
working together to solve this problem
that's been a nut job what you're
mentioning has been going on for a long
time and it's it's a sad event a lot of
sad events in this country but what
we're doing is now we're working on the
virus we're working on that hidden enemy
and I think we're doing a great job on
as good a job I actually think Trump's
saying he's not looking to ban abortion
and Deborah came up with numbers
yesterday just say that if we did
nothing you could lose 2.2 up to two
point and maybe beyond I don't know
maybe
but 2.2 million people if we did nothing
and I can't tell you what the
unfortunate final toll is going to be
but it's going to be a very small
fraction of that
so Trump mostly not taking the bait
actually think with what we're doing
please go ahead
are you considering all a nationwide
stay at home order I know there's a lot
of states that have put them in place
but some haven't I'm just wondering if
you were considering some sort of broad
stay at home owner and I have a question
for dr. Burks well we've talked about it
we obviously there are some parts of the
of the country that are in far deeper
trouble than others there are other
parts that frankly are not in trouble at
all so hopefully we're gonna be able to
keep it that way by doing what we're
doing so we talked about quarantine as
you know the other day a group came to
me and they wanted to do the quarantine
and I said let's think about it and we
did it we studied it and by the time the
evening came it just was something that
was very unwieldy very tough to enforce
and something we didn't want to do but
we did advisory and I think that's doing
well I mean I I see I look at the
streets you look at New York where this
I look down Fifth Avenue today they were
showing a shot of Fifth Avenue and sort
of primetime and there was almost nobody
on Fifth Avenue I've never seen that
before there was no car there was no
anything so I think the people in this
country have done an incredible job if
we do that we will let you know but it's
pretty unlikely I would think at this
time okay it's a quick question for dr.
Bruce so dr. Burks if you don't mind
you had mentioned today that this model
that predicts a hundred thousand deaths
is if we do things almost perfectly so I
wanted to know are we currently doing
things almost perfectly or are there
more things we need to be doing to cap
you know to not exceed that hundred
thousand two hundred thousand model
please come thank you I think that's a
really great question and tomorrow we'll
go through all of the graphs and all the
information that we took to the
president for the decision but when you
and I just want to thank the data team
that's working day and night to get I
mean I usually get my data about 2:00
a.m. from them and they assimilate all
the data from all the state's data and
when you look at all of the states
together all of them are moving in
exactly the same curves and so that's
why we really believe this needs to be
federal guidance so that every state
understands that it does look like two
cases today that become 20 that become
200 yes mm and that's what we're trying
to prevent
and I think states still have that
opportunity but they're going to have to
do all of these recommended I mean these
recommendations are recommendations that
the globe is using and so we really do
recommend that every governor every
mayor looks very carefully and ensures
that their communities are utilizing
these guidance they're really looking
more like vertical lines than curves it
is amazing you look at Louisiana and for
a long time it was just it was just
staying and nothing and then all of a
sudden I look one day and I see a lot
and a lot it's called a virus spreads
virally now we're working very carefully
and very powerfully with them we're
building hospitals who are building a
lot of different things for Louisiana so
it's very important yeah place card this
could be seasonal seasonal cyclical
virus so in maybe both of you could
comment on this and dr. Burks as well
are you prepared for this to strike
again say in the fall all the efforts
that are taking place right now to
contain this to be proactive and I hope
it doesn't happen doctor would you like
to say something about that I hope it
doesn't happen this is increasingly an
important issue because it probably will
in fact I would anticipate that that
there you go happen because of the
degree of
miscibility however if you come back in
the fall it will be a totally different
ballgame of what happened when we first
got hit with it in the beginning of this
year there will be several things that
will be different our ability to go out
and be able to test identify isolate and
contact trace will be orders of
magnitude better than what it was just a
couple of months ago in addition we have
a number of clinical trials that are
looking at a variety of therapeutic
interventions we hope one or more of
them will be available and importantly
as I mentioned to you many times at
these briefings is that we have a
vaccine that's on track and multiple
other candidates so I would anticipate
that you know a year to a year and a
half we'd be able to do it on there an
emergency use that's not the fault
seeing an efficacy signal we may be able
to even use a vaccine at the next season
so things are going to be very very
different what we're going through now
is going to be more than just lessons
learned it's gonna be things that we
have available to us that we did not
have before Scott
thank you Scott Gottlieb your former FDA
Commissioner wrote a roadmap for
recovery after the corona virus he
suggests that the the roadmap suggest
that everybody wear a mask in public is
that something that the task force
thinks is a good idea
we haven't discussed it to that extent
but it's certainly something we could
discuss we're getting certainly the
number of masks that you need we are in
the process of talking about things I
saw his suggestion on that so we'll take
a look at it for a period of time not
forever I mean you know we want our
country back we're not gonna be wearing
masks forever but it could be for a
short period of Trump saying that maybe
it's a just back into gear everybody
wear a mask all the time something like
that happening for a period of day
that's a huge hope it would be very
limited another run on masks doctors
they'll come back and say for the rest
of our lives we have to wear masks the
roadmap also talks about doing GPS for a
social distancing maybe follow-ups
following people's
and hotels for isolation for people
giving them free hotel rooms are those
ideas that you're looking at well the
GPS that's very severe idea I've been
hearing about a GPS so what happens a
siren goes off if you get too close to
somebody that's pretty severe but he's
somebody he was with me for a long time
he worked they did a great job at FDA so
so we're gonna take it a look I just I
just received it a little while ago he
sent it over so very good go ahead let's
give it a shot what do you say to
Americans who are upset with you over
the way you downplayed this crisis over
the last couple of months we have very
much under control in this country the
corona virus is very much under control
in the USA it's going to disappear it's
like a miracle it will disappear March
4th we have a very small number of
people in this country infected March
10th we're prepared we're doing a great
job with it it will go away just a calm
it will go away what do you say to
Americans will they do got this wrong
and I do want them to stay calm and we
are doing a great job if you look at
those individual statements they're all
true stay calm you should have read we
have 15 cases and soon it'll be zero oh
it is going away and it will go away and
we're gonna have a great victory and
it's people like you and CNN that say
things like that that it's why people
just don't want to listen to CN anymore
you could ask a normal question the
statements I made or I want to keep the
country calm I don't want panic in the
country I could cause panic much better
than even you I could do much I would
make you look like a minor league player
but you know what I don't want to do
that I want to have our country become
and strong and fight and win and it will
go away and it is incredible the job
that all of these people are doing
putting them all together the job that
they're doing I am very proud of the job
they're doing that Mike Pence is doing
that the task force has done that
Honeywell and Proctor and Gamble and
Mike and all of these people have done
I'm very proud it's it's almost a
miracle and it is the way it's all come
together
and instead of asking a nasty snarky
question like that you should ask a real
question and other than that I'm gonna
go to somebody else real journalism is
quoting people and asking them to react
you express some concern in the past
that medical supplies were going out the
back door and that perhaps some
hospitals were doing things well I rest
what was told to me by a tremendous
power in the business he said that at a
New York Hospital for a long period of
time he was giving 10,000 maybe maximum
20,000 masks over a short time and all
of a sudden he's giving 300,000 and I
said no matter how bad this is could
that be possible he said no so there's
only a couple of things that could
happen is it going out the back door and
I've reported it to the city and let the
city take a look at it but when you go
from 10,000 masks to 300,000 masks like
over the same period this crap again
there's something going on now I'm not
making any charges but when everyone's
looking for masks and by the way that's
another thing we're making a lot of
masks and the sterilization process is
going to save a lot of time and a lot of
masks but when when you have the biggest
distributor of product that distributes
to many of the big hospitals and
hospital chains and he brings up a
statistic like that and I know you're
trying to make a big deal out of it but
you shouldn't be you should actually go
over to the hospital and find out why
you shouldn't be asking me I'm just
saying that's the way it is you should
go over there as a great reporter I have
no idea who you are but that's okay you
should go over there go to the hospital
and find out how come you used to get
10,000 masks and you had a full house
answer corona bike city always fall and
how come now you have 300,000 masks
despite the virus at all you have threes
how do you go from ten to 300,000 yeah
go to a hospital at this point for no
reason potentially getting the virus or
spreading it and ask why people during
corona virus are using masks a thousand
masks so what I think you should do is a
I'm sure you're a wonderful
investigative reporter you should go to
the
spell to find out what okay yeah Steve
please come on Steve well it's it's so
bad for the economy but the economy is
number two on my list first I want to
save a lot of lives we're gonna get the
economy back I think the economy is
going to come back very fast Steve's
just asking about the economy what's it
like
we basically shut down our country right
and we did that in order to keep people
separated keep people apart they're not
working in offices that not in airplanes
together you know we really shut it down
and you know 150 hundred and fifty one
other countries they're pretty much shut
down but here were they we had the
greatest economy in the world we had the
greatest economy in the history of our
country and I had to go from doing a
great job for three years to shutting it
down but you know what we're gonna build
it up and we're gonna build it up
rapidly and I think in the end we'll be
stronger for it we learned a lot we
learned a lot and I have to say we've
had great relationships with a lot of
countries China sent us some stuff which
was terrific Russia sent us a very very
large plane load of things medical
equipment element which was very nice
other countries sent us things that I
was very surprised that very happily
surprised we learned a lot we're
learning a lot and we're also learning
that the concept of borders is very
important to Steve it's very important
having borders is very very important
this ran together we have done an
incredible job the economy is going to
come back
my focus is saving lives that's the only
focus I can have we're gonna bring the
economy back and we'll bring it back
fast yeah please
please Thank You mr. Thank You mr.
president you said several times that
the United States has ramped up testing
Oh talk a little quicker a little louder
mr. president you said several times
that the United States is ramped up
testing but the United States is still
not testing per capita as many res right
people as other countries like South
Korea why is that and when do you think
that that number will be on par with
other countries very much in part it's
not like per capita we have areas of
country that's very wet I know South
Korea better than anybody it's not very
tight you know how many people are in
sold yeah you know big the city of Seoul
is 38 million people that's bigger than
anything we have 38 million people all
tightly the point is we have 340 million
total we have vast farmlands we have
vast areas where they don't have much of
a problem that's where the question is
per capita doesn't apply that that oh my
god and more tests what I didn't I
didn't talk about per capita it's a per
capita tests by far than any country in
the world by far our testing is also
better than any country in the world and
when you look at that as simple as that
looks that's something that's a game
chance your country wants that every
country so rather than asking a question
like that you should congratulate the
people that have done this testing
because we inherited this administration
inherited a broken system a system that
was absolute bomb assume that didn't
work it was okay for a tiny small group
of people but once you got beyond that
it didn't work we have built an
incredible system to the fact where we
have now done more tests than any other
country in the world not prepared now
the technology is really booming I just
spoke to well I spoke to a lot I'm not
going to even mention I spoke to a
number of different testing companies
today yeah and the job that they've done
and the job that they're doing is
incredible but when Abbott comes out and
does this so quickly it's really unreal
in fact can we blame this on the law
really I have to say that stands out in
the job and I think I can say this I
don't want to insult anybody else but
Roch Roch is
been incredible in the testing job
they've done and they're ramping it up
exponentially it's a spa and you should
be saying congratulations instead of
asking a really snarky question exactly
what you mean by that you should be
saying congratulations to the men and
women who have done this job who have
inherited a broken testing system
journalists should just congratulate
Trump and if you don't say it I'll say
it I want to congratulate all of the
people you have done a fantastic job and
we will see you all tomorrow thank you
very much thank you thank you
wow what a weird particularly unhinged
press conference a very very strange
situation and I'm since it was a shorter
one I'm going to stay and do Super chats
and thank people so stick around make
sure if you're watching on YouTube hit
that like button and hit the subscribe
button a lot of people visibly shaking
their heads
hopefully stunned by Donald Trump's be
heart B's bizarre childish and ignorant
behavior but all extraordinarily very
very strange if you're joining us on
Twitter to follow you're joining us on
YouTube make sure to LIKE and subscribe
very very important likes and subscribes
mean another stream tomorrow ladies and
gentlemen is this my pit no that's not
my pillow guys sorry when the my pillow
guy talked about god that was the
craziest moment let me see if I can find
that my pillow God basically saying
Trump was heaven-sent here he is on
November 8 2016 to change the course we
were on God had been taken out of our
schools and lives a nation had turned
his back on God and I encourage you use
this time at home to get back to home to
get back in the word read our Bibles and
spend time with our families yeah our
president gave us so much hope we're
just a few short months ago anyway I
think you guys get it just like a
complete and utter disaster
of every every single kind and very very
wild and wacky and just who knows what
what who knows what of that was
and in advance and the guy you know it's
just a disgusting disgusting guy who I
hope makes the masks right I mean make
the masks of course everybody make the
masks let me say thank you to some new
members I want to thank some very very
important people
Teresa banks is new member number 12
today at join pakman.com Jordan balance
is new member number 13 today
Thank You Jordan Alexander oh no I
already think that's a duplicate there
hold on a second William McKenna is new
member number 14 today thanks William
Sheila Swanberg is new member number 15
today I also want to say thanks to Tammy
Houser who's new member number 16 at
join pakman.com dawn dawson is new
member number 17 today allison woodward
new member number 18 Eric bishop is new
member number 19 James DeRose is new
member number 20 Marty Oden doll Oden
doll is new member number 21 thank you
so much I also want to say thanks to
John Watkins new member number 22 and
Raghu Auriga is new member number 23
today
can't forget about Joseph Anderson new
member number 24 and Nate Barton number
25 Wow 25 on the dot
let's go for 50 my friends and as I
mentioned you know we are now last week
we were we were in pretty good shape but
we're getting hit pretty hard because of
the the virus we had some advertisers
sadly drop out we had we're down about
3540 percent in YouTube revenue so
really we were we're counting on folks
who are signing up for memberships
during streams quite frankly to sort of
level things out so that we don't do any
we've not laid anybody off we've not cut
ours or we've we've not done anything
like that let me say some Twitter I'm
sorry twitch thank yous knock Talia as
well as Ozzy boy and Jay square as well
as a user who goes by the name why am i
sticky geez and I
Compu bear sending in some bits and
folks signing up very very much
appreciate that thank you so much let's
get to some super chats okay I may not
be able to get back to everybody but
let's at least look at what some folks
have been sending elem gorac says if you
want to compare what competent
leadership looks like during a crisis
check out press briefings by Prime
Minister Jacinda Arden of New Zealand
yeah I've seen some of those Josef's
Picone says they say it's a choice
between lives and economy but if we let
it rip and millions get sicker that die
what will that do to the economy yeah
you need people alive and able to work
in order to have an economy
Jamie lay me says results in minutes
make Trump do it live then I would love
to see Trump take another test I don't
think that that was a working I think
that that's just the shell that they
showed Sam Dean says in my opinion Trump
seems exhausted very lethargic parity
Ren says don't you have to verify before
implementing the cure yeah that you do
have to and of course we don't have a
cure yet we have some ideas of things
that could be tested
Daniel Ocean says Chinese importers are
now flooding the u.s. with K and 95 the
Chinese equivalent at quadruple the
prices while banning exports of n95
price gouge a Pedro Miramon says that's
idiotic sterilization compromises the
physical integrity of the mask that's a
lot of BS I've heard both sides of that
I've heard the masks can be properly
sterilized if it's done correctly right
that's not a guarantee
zesty African says Trump has no drip or
swag Christy J says must say it is
highly nauseating to hear the thank you
for your leadership over and over yeah
the required SiC of fancy at these
things is absolutely sick let's see
cacus Umbra says Trump likes listing
numbers but what percentage of state
requests are being fulfilled
excellent question which was asked of
Trump yesterday he didn't answer it
Timmy Lunsford says how did you do this
every day pack because of you guys
thanks to you guys I
I do it every day owl aquatic says he
must throw pillows at the press F paper
towels name withheld says he's getting
huge kickback mascot says what is
happening pare tearin' says WTF yet
these were the reactions while my pillow
guy was on this rant
Oh anyway it ended alright very good
almost a handshake there but Trump uh
successfully avoiding it
Sam Dean says I wonder if this won't
make tea rump a hat guy jr. style wait
what Anthony Sanchez says welcome to the
coronavirus Awards live from the White
House if you have a question or comment
for me it will pop up on the screen if
you're watching on YouTube and send it
via super chat that's what I'm reading
here cacus Umbra says infomercial in the
Rose Garden yeah it was mostly companies
talking about what great jobs they're
doing
Robert Archer says I figured the ShamWow
guy would be up next I think that guys
on the left I think that ShamWow guy
Vincent offer I think is that isn't that
his name anybody know I think that he's
a lefty so I'd be shocked to see him
saying Trump is God's gift from God I
think he's also a Jewish guy so I don't
know that I don't know that he would see
Trump as being a God's gift of any kind
iridescent Inc says merchants of death
Adam Lasky says these are ridiculous
economy over people ffs name withheld
says where's the Charmin CEO yeah we
should have him out talking about
double-ply Christie J says this is a
trump rally just disgusting it's it was
absolutely disgusting
we do have a hype train happening on
Twitch I want to say thanks to casualty
as well as FRA c66 and Rube Goldberg
machine for supporting over on Twitch
very much appreciated also want to say
thank you to Tyler Hansen whose new
member number 26 today at join
pakman.com thanks Tyler
I very much appreciate appreciate your
support on my website
Sam Dean says there isn't any
information or advice here just product
pitches and presidential praise
what is this did they pay for their 15
or 25 seconds I'm as confused by it as
you are Sam aurilla podge says you're
the best David Thank You Nabil Kaveri
says Trump is pure ignorance
David 2020 John Kovich says I performed
multiple tests on kovat patients today
and there is nothing more terrifying
than putting on the same and 95 masks
all day thank you for your work John I
have multiple friends who are emergency
room doctors here in Boston who have
indeed been advised one mask all day one
mask all day and a lot of people are
dealing with that zero elements of
reality says it was a beautiful call
with the governor's yeah Seoul says I
think the media makes Trump nervous
anything other than glowing praise from
spot Trump finds to be nasty or snarky a
pamda Monia says they better not cancel
the vents if it's past the peak because
we're probably gonna get a relapse next
winter yeah at this point we need all
the ventilators we need bigger
stockpiles states need bigger stockpiles
federal government needs a bigger
stockpile but importantly it's not just
the stockpile that matters it's
immediately deploying them in January
Trump should have started moving around
stockpiles to likely points of hotspots
immediately should have just been done
right away let me say thank you to Kayla
Contreras whose new member number 27
today at join pakman.com thanks very
much Kayla really appreciate your
support today parity or sorry Yolanda
bellydance
says keep up the great work pare tearin'
says let fowey take the lead that's an
idea thanks to shoot cut deliver for the
super chat Joseph van Scoy says New
Orleans had nothing and then all of a
sudden they had more and then more yet
this is what Trump doesn't seem to get
how viruses work he's like you know some
places only have a hundred cases we
don't have to worry well but then a
thousand undred becomes a thousand
that becomes 5000 it's almost like it
grows virally yeah Trump doesn't seem to
get that still kunal thing says what are
your thoughts on a national lockdown I
mean listen I think the next 30 days we
should take it very seriously if it
wouldn't cause undue panic
whatever the strictest reasonable
measures are we should do them because
if we're doing 30 days let's do 30 days
and do it right and again as a as a
reminder we are expecting that the peak
will be on April 15th but in understand
that we're really talking about you know
more like April 10th all the way to
April 22nd is really going to be the
peak it's really gonna be a 12-day Peak
by all estimates this is kovat 19 dot
health data or get you know the we need
to go fully fully fully on and then
hopefully by understand that by May 1st
we are likely to be at the same level
that we are going to be five days from
now so May 1st which is well past the
peak is going to be worse than today in
all likelihood and this is what you have
to understand when you look at these
statistics and these estimates and again
this estimate is updated every day by a
medical doctor who specializes in health
metrics and will start to fine-tune but
this is the way the curve is looking as
of right now
JAF 94 that says fascinating if masks
become a normal month later yeah I you
know it was it was leaked yesterday
supposedly that the CDC was considering
telling everybody to wear masks then it
was denied now Trump is saying well
maybe we are thinking about it that'll
cause another run on masks of course if
that's done it's a complicated thing
Steven K says DPS is my antidote to 24/7
Fox News in my house that's brutal cacus
Umbra says I know how I know broken
systems better than anyone that is
something Trump actually has expertise
with Gabriel Garcia says this man just
said Seoul has 35 million inhabitant
yeah let's see soul population is 9
million very good so Trump completely
out of control
I'm guessing South Korea population is
51 million yeah so who knows what the
let's see Seoul metro area population 25
million yep okay so 35 million was a
worthless trash number that Trump pulled
out of who knows where meaningless
meaningless number Jena Nix says will
fake news narrative lose water if enough
reporters ask obvious questions while
deaths continue that's my hope Sam Dean
did his bull chip malfunction at the end
there yeah I don't know he seemed to
kind of like lose steam on the bs flawed
spirit says are we sure Trump isn't a
robot he seems only to have access to a
finite number of exe s and they're
somehow all corrupted dreams thief says
didn't he sound sick he always sounds
that way quite frankly Dru goose says
when will the next chess tournament be I
was working during the last one yeah you
know as a just as a kind of like
coronavirus stick we're staying at home
sort of thing we did a chess tournament
last Tuesday and incredibly 500 people
played in it and it was great fun and
people started saying you should do it
daily you should do it weekly I'm
certainly considering doing it monthly I
might consider doing it weekly during
coronavirus if people really want it
done but people are gonna have to email
me and let me know like you can't just
put in the chat do it if you really want
a weekly chess tournament like maybe
this week we could do it again Wednesday
night maybe I don't have anything going
on that's for damn sure we'll see and
you know people saying is that more
important than the virus the whole point
is we want to do things to build
community keep we know people are at
home etc so that's that's the idea let
me say thanks to Elizabeth Schmitt
Matson who is new member number 28 today
at join pakman.com Elizabeth thank you
so much for your support the membership
support really very important to us
during this complicated era
keep it real cam says when will he take
responsibility for the state we are I
guess I don't need this anymore for the
state we're in right now he has been in
charge long enough to make changes yeah
you know in year four of your presidency
talking about Obama didn't leave us
prepared for a pandemic it's like how
long are you gonna do that Matt Allen
has grabbed a youtube membership a rich
ropa thak says Eric Bischoff used to be
general manager of WWE Raw I don't know
anything about it I have no idea Sydnor
Denver has grabbed a soy boy level
YouTube membership Casey Bates says is
there anything that can be done to
challenge ignorant Trump done to
challenge ignorant Trump answers like
the per capita question on testing you
know there really isn't and I used to
think the next reporter should just ask
the same question again but I saw a very
good article saying you know when you
confront Trump about one lie he'll tell
four more lies and it becomes a [ __ ]
show and it's like a Gish gallop so I I
actually don't know the answer I
actually don't know the answer to that
thoughts on Cuomo Biden swap I
understand why people are thinking about
that I don't think it's going to happen
love inspired seven says please help me
understand why consistently lying to the
American people wasn't considered as an
article impeachment because he'd never
win you'd never win on that it could
have easily been proven yes but the
question is is it impeachable I don't
think you you even remember Republicans
control the Senate it would not have
made a difference
thanks to Bjorn Eric Knudsen for the
YouTube subscription Matt bond says says
thoughts on River at Tampa Bay pastor
being charged River at Tampa Bay pastor
being charged Tim is that because of the
full evangelical church pastor charged
coronavirus let me see if I can find
that Florida pastor arrested after
holding church services despite
coronavirus orders may find that rodney
howard-browne
of the river at tampa bay allegedly
showed reckless disregard for human life
and put hundreds of people from his
congregate
at risk I agree with it I agree with it
listen if you're an individual and
you're saying hey you know what I'm
going out and I'm going to you know I'm
gonna go out and get get takeout or at
you know whatever that's very different
than these megachurches having these
absolutely insane numbers of people show
up you can't do it you can't do it
Stephen case has to the my pillow guy
remember Matthew nineteen twenty four it
is easier for a camel to go through the
eye of a needle than for a rich man to
enter the kingdom of God more EP says
thoughts on passing legislation on what
stations can report as news other
thoughts on how to bring back the
polarized right I have a lot of segments
on my youtube channel about the
deprogramming of the right so I won't
get into it today we'll see suggests
maybe Trump doesn't know what per capita
means that's actually possible
Frank Witter says how do i gift
memberships the easiest way right now
Frank is when you go to my website and
to the membership page you type in your
payment info but the recipients name and
email so like you can hit the sign up
button you put in you know like if you
want to give this to little Sally you
would put little Sally and Sally's email
you know make a password for her all
that stuff but then you do the payment
info that's really the best way right
now that I can suggest doing the gift
memberships better system someday in the
future Ricky Williams says reporters
should just ask Trump to define per
capita yeah do you know what per capita
means might be a better way to say it
thanks also to Tinto Rose for the
YouTube subscription Lance Powers says
how large of an impact does pure denial
have to do with our society's reaction
to this virus I think many do not want
to believe this is happening I think
that that is a factor I think that
that's definitely a factor that is
impacting the reticence of many people
to say we've got to stay the hell home
also tinto Rose is a new member at join
pakman.com number 29 also thanks to
Bianca Sammy
whose member number 30 today at join
pakman.com and lastly I do want to say
thanks to mr. Jay breezy who subscribed
with prime as well as Daz key and LD
hunter
Joey Jim nine nine nine all of whom
subscribed on Twitch alright that's it
for me today if there's a tomorrow it's
a big one there gonna be I think doctors
will actually give us data which is what
I prefer I don't really want to hear
from Trump so join me tomorrow for the
broadcast show the YouTube clips and
then another coronavirus livestream
remember if you're watching on twitch
hit that follow button if you're
watching on youtube subscribe and like
so nothing is more important in these
difficult times than subscribe and like
I'll see you guys tomorrow we're going
to continue publishing YouTube clips for
the rest of the day